hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
here's a noted right-wing lunatic saying
something that actually completely makes
sense
let's go to dan bongino the host of
unfiltered on saturday night stan your
quick emotional reaction i think
everyone's a little emotional here
about this raid
yeah i mean you think this is some third
world [ __ ] right here let me say it
again third world [ __ ]
i mean every word of that
i don't care that it's cable news i was
a federal agent i raised my right hand
and i swore to protect and defend the
constitution united states and i love
this country this is a freaking disgrace
a disgrace
we don't live in cuba we don't live
under kim jong-un
we live in a constitutional republic a
representative democracy
you have a bunch of fbi agents raiding
the home of a former president because
they don't like his politics are you
kidding me
you've spent this whole show jesse and
i've spent my entire time either on fox
or on my podcast exposing the left for
claiming russia interfered in election
as hillary clinton played paid off a
bunch of foreign agents her team
literally to fabricate a story that
occupied the nation for four years
what's she doing right now getting a
manicure in freaking chappaqua
she's not doing squat
nothing hunter biden is having sex on
tape while doing crack
while doing crack and what is he doing
he's living in a malibu mansion and yet
the president the former president who
whether you agree with him or not on his
claims about the election whether you
agree or not we still live in a country
where you were allowed to challenge
an election there's even a process the
eca
the electoral count act you may not like
it but it's a process how do i know it's
a process because some people are trying
to reform it you may not like it but now
you send the fbi let me tell you
something i have been i have paid due
deference to the fbi for a long time and
a lot of listeners didn't like it
because i work with some very good
people over there who have since retired
the management of the fbi has now
shredded any single shred sliver of
credibility this agency had left
nobody will take them seriously from
this point on it is over you've heard
the examples stone manafort cohen over
and over are they good guys are they bad
guys i don't know i don't care i don't
know them all i'm telling you is you
cannot tell me we still live in a
constitutional republic and not the
freaking third world when you have
hillary clinton paying foreign agents to
interfere with an election people lying
on the road repeatedly hunter biden
doing crack on tape and what happens
where are the federal agents they're not
in malibu they're not in chappaqua
they're in mar-a-lago this is some third
world garbage that happened tonight and
i'm telling you the fbi management
here's the solution last thing
we have now got to win in 2022 you have
no choice now folks oh we don't like the
swampy republicans i don't like them
either republicans may not be the
solution to your problems but democrats
are certainly the cause of all your
problems right now if there was ever a
clarion call to remove your ass from the
seat and go vote in 2022 this is it